Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. For more than 200 episodes, we've covered everything from the foundations of ancient Babylon to the origins of the war in Ukraine. But no topic has excited
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。你好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。在过去的两百多集里，我们探讨了从古代巴比伦的奠基到乌克兰战争起源的方方面面。但没有任何一个主题
more interest, enthusiasm and curiosity among the great Britishish public than today's one of the truly great questions of history what has been the importance the influence and the impact of the pigeon tom holland i'm so i'm so excited about this episode you know i i think it was january was it i raised it um. I suggested doing it. Seems like years ago, frankly, Tom. Yeah, Dominic. So you, I think it's fair to say, have treated initially this subject with levity. You did not regard it as a fit subject for historical inquiry. That is an outrageous claim, Tom, and one I absolutely reject. Well, Dominic, I don't actually have the evidence to prove it.
比今天这个历史上的真正重大问题——鸽子的重要性、影响力和冲击力——更能激发广大英国公众的兴趣、热情和好奇心了。托姆·霍兰，我太——我太兴奋了，你知道的，我想那是1月吧？我提出了这个……我建议做这个。老实说，感觉好像是几年前的事了，托姆。是的，多米尼克。所以，我觉得可以这么说，你一开始对这个话题持轻率态度。你并不认为它是一个适合进行历史探究的话题。这是一个极其无理的指控，托姆，我绝对不接受。好吧，多米尼克，我其实没有证据来证明这一点。
You have the documentary evidence to prove the documentary evidence to prove it i i'm sure they're the old tweet or something out there with you sneering at it as a subject but but but we have both agreed haven't we that actually the relationship of humans to animals to creatures is a really fascinating one so we've talked about doing um horses yeah and and dogs of course have been a constant theme of our early episodes yes killed weren't they yes i mean that job for a while which is a shame but today we're gonna have dead pigeons and so the reason i thought that actually um together with horses and dogs pigeons are probably um the most interesting animals to look at in terms of how humans have understood them the uses that humans have put them to yeah and also i kind
你有记录证据来证明……有记录证据来证明……我确信外面一定有你的某个旧推文或其他东西，带着嘲讽的语气把它当作一个话题，但——但是我们都同意了，不是吗？实际上，人类与动物、与生物之间的关系是一个非常迷人的话题。所以我们谈论过马，是的，当然，狗也是我们早期节目的一个经常出现的主题。是的，它们被杀死了，不是吗？是的，有一段时间它们遭遇了那种命运，这太遗憾了。但今天我们要讲的是死鸽子。所以，我觉得其实……除了马和狗之外，鸽子可能是最有趣的动物，无论是从人类如何理解它们、人类如何利用它们，是的，还有……
of perhaps the the darkest theme of all um the way in which humans have um impacted and eaten them yeah well have have have shot and wiped them out as well yeah so extinction is also a part of the history of humanity's relationship to animals however so the reason why i thought we should do pigeons yeah it's because i went to an Advent service last year. And there I found myself sitting next to Gordon Carrera, the BBC security correspondent, author of many fantastic books on history of security services, all that kind of stuff. Presenter of TV programs on MI5, all that kind of stuff but he told me that he had written a book which i had missed called operation columba the secret pigeon service the untold story of world war ii resistance in europe that as it suggests has pigeons absolutely at its heart and gordon said you must do pigeons so gordon the time has come we are doing pigeons Should we welcome you with a sort of a pigeon style coup or something?
也许是最黑暗的主题——人类对它们的影响和食用它们的历史，是的，还有把它们射杀并消灭的历史。所以灭绝也是人类与动物关系史的一部分。然而，我之所以觉得我们应该讲鸽子，是因为我去年去参加了一个将临期礼拜。在那里，我发现自己坐在 BBC 安全事务记者戈登·卡雷拉（Gordon Carrera）旁边。他是许多关于安全服务历史等精彩书籍的作者，也是关于军情五处等节目的主持人。但他告诉我，他写过一本我漏掉的书，叫做《科伦巴行动：秘密信鸽服务：欧洲二战抵抗运动的鲜为人知的故事》，顾名思义，这本书的核心绝对是鸽子。戈登说，你们一定要讲鸽子。所以，戈登，时机已到，我们在讲鸽子了。我们是不是应该用某种类似鸽子式的政变之类的方式来欢迎你？
Well, thank you. I've never been called that before. I'm so grateful for coming on because I'm very excited about pigeons. I did sense that there might be some people out there who might think it wasn't a worthy subject for such a lofty, high-minded podcast. So I'm looking forward for the chance to kind of make the case for pigeons, in my mind, as the superheroes of history. Oh, that's a big claim. Who saved us in the past and may even save us in the future. That's the claim I'm going to make. So maybe you could start off. I mean, I notoriously know nothing and take no interest in science or the natural world at all. So for an absolute ignoramus like me, what is a pigeon?
谢谢你。我以前从未被人这样称呼过。我非常感激能来，因为我对鸽子非常兴奋。我确实感觉到，可能会有一些人认为这不是一个适合如此崇高、高尚的播客的主题。所以我很期待有机会为鸽子正名，在我心目中，它们是历史上的超级英雄。哦，这口气可不小。在过去拯救了我们，甚至可能在未来拯救我们的那些。这就是我要提出的观点。所以，也许你可以先介绍一下。我的意思是，我出了名地对科学或自然界一无所知，也完全不感兴趣。所以对于像我这样一个绝对的无知者来说，鸽子到底是什么？
Good question to start with. The first thing to say is that what we call a pigeon and what we think of as a pigeon around us is actually a dove. And basically doves have good PR, pigeons have bad PR. But the pigeon, the one we think of is the rock dove. And basically doves have good PR, pigeons have bad PR. But the pigeon, the one we think of is the rock dove. And there are other types of pigeons as well. And we might come to some of those, the kind of passenger pigeon and the wood pigeon and different types. But Columbolivia is the kind of famous pigeon. And what makes it really interesting and unusual is that it's very friendly with people. So first of all, rock dove, because it doesn't so much nest in trees, but it loves rocky ledges. So originally cliffs. But the fact that it was happy in cliffs meant
这是一个很好的开场问题。首先要说的是，我们所说的鸽子以及我们周围认为的鸽子，实际上是鸠。基本上，鸠的名声好，鸽子的名声坏。但这种鸽子，也就是我们所认为的那种，是岩鸽。基本上，鸠的名声好，鸽子的名声坏。但这种鸽子，也就是我们所认为的那种，是岩鸽。还有其他类型的鸽子。我们可能会谈到其中一些，比如旅鸽、林鸽以及不同的品种。但原鸽（Columba livia）是那种著名的鸽子。让它变得非常有趣且与众不同的是，它对人类非常友好。首先，岩鸽之所以不是在树上筑巢，而是喜欢岩石峭壁，原本是悬崖。但它在悬崖上生活得很愉快这一事实意味着
it was quite happy on rocky ledges. So people found that they could build what became dovecotes, you know, places where pigeons would quite happily come and live. And also eventually you get plenty of rocky ledges in cities. So that's why we see so many in the cities that they're intrinsically happy in a kind of human environment. They're also very friendly with people. They're not scared of us. You don't need to cage them. They'll come and eat out of your hand.
它在岩石峭壁上也很适应。所以人们发现，它们可以建造后来成为鸽舍的东西——你知道的，也就是鸽子会非常乐意前来居住的地方。而且，最终城市里也有大量的岩石峭壁。这就是为什么我们在城市里看到那么多鸽子的原因，它们天生就适应这种人类环境。它们对人类也非常友好。它们不怕我们。你不需要把它们关在笼子里。它们会走过来从你手中吃东西。
And that means they're easy to domesticate. So right from the earliest days of history, it's meant they've been able to have this very interesting relationship with humans because they're friendly with us. They can be bred very easily for whatever reason, ranging from food to sport to their superpower, which hopefully we'll come to in a bit. So Gordon, before we come on to that, the superpower and the uses that pigeons have been put to by humans, you've talked about how humanity's relationship with the pigeon is very,
这意味着它们很容易被驯化。因此，从历史的最早时期起，这就意味着它们能够与人类建立这种非常有趣的联系，因为它们对我们很友好。无论出于什么目的，从食物、体育运动到它们的超能力——希望我们一会儿会谈到——它们都可以非常容易地被繁殖。所以，戈登，在我们谈到这一点之前，也就是超能力以及人类对鸽子的利用，你刚才提到人类与鸽子的关系是非常……
very ancient. Could we just begin by looking at the, dare I say, sacral quality that the pigeon has had? Well, because they are absolutely woven into some of the foundational mythologies, so the Bible most obviously. So I guess probably the most famous episode in myth that pigeons have featured in is Noah and his ark. That's right. And the story, of course, is that the birds are sent out and the raven is sent out and doesn't come back. And the pigeon comes back with word that there's land. It's one example of where, one of the few examples where Game of Thrones is historically inaccurate, because of course, in Game of Thrones, they use ravens to communicate. In reality, it was pigeons which would get, it was would get sent out. And if you look at the Noah's Ark, it's the raven fails,
非常古老的。我们能否先来看看，我敢说，鸽子所具有的那种圣洁的品质？嗯，因为它们绝对交织在一些基础神话中，最明显的就是《圣经》。所以我想，神话中最著名的关于鸽子的插曲大概就是诺亚方舟了。没错。而这个故事当然是，鸟儿被放飞了，乌鸦被放飞了却没有回来。而鸽子带回了有陆地的消息。这是《权力的游戏》在历史上不准确的少数几个例子之一，因为在《权力的游戏》中，他们使用乌鸦来传递信息。实际上，被放飞的是鸽子。如果你看看诺亚方舟，乌鸦失败了，
but the pigeon, the dove succeeds and brings back news. And it's the association of pigeons with peace and chastity, which comes very early. And this comes from people actually observing the mating rituals of the pigeons. And how one of the reasons is just how affectionate they are with each other. And the male pigeon really will woo the female pigeon very attentively. And then the view from classical times onwards was that they became very chaste. They were very loyal to each other. And so pigeons start to be seen as symbols of peace, of chastity, of fidelity. And you see that role as one part of their kind of spiritual role in the traditions and in many of the religious traditions around the world.
但鸽子——也就是鸠——成功了，并带回了消息。正是鸽子与和平、贞洁的联系，这种联系出现得很早。这来自于人们对鸽子交配仪式的观察。其中的原因之一就是它们彼此之间是多么深情。雄鸽确实会非常体贴地向雌鸽求爱。从古典时代开始，人们的看法就是它们变得非常贞洁。它们对彼此非常忠诚。因此，鸽子开始被视为和平、贞洁和忠诚的象征。你会看到这种角色作为它们在传统以及世界各地许多宗教传统中的精神角色的一部分。
You see this in Christianity. You, of course, see the dove as the Holy Spirit descending from above. The Holy Spirit comes down as a dove. You also see them used as animal sacrifices in religion. But Gordon, a very stupid question to, again, reflect my natural history ignorance. So why are they called doves? So no one talks about it. I mean, if somebody said the Holy Spirit, the pigeon of the Holy Spirit, I mean, that sounds faintly comical.
你在基督教中也能看到这一点。当然，你会看到鸽子作为圣灵从天而降。圣灵化作鸽子降临。你还会看到它们在宗教中被用作动物祭品。但是，戈登，这是一个非常愚蠢的问题，再次反映了我对自然历史的无知。那么，为什么它们被称为“鸠”（dove）呢？所以没有人谈论这一点。我的意思是，如果有人说圣灵，圣灵的鸽子，我的意思是，这听起来有点滑稽。
But the dove, you know, sounds, we take it for granted. So why the branding? Well, the branding is just unfortunate branding to some extent. And I think the pigeon has just had a bad bad pr and uh you know there are differences and there are different types of doves but i would make the case that in many cases in history where they are talking about doves they're really talking about pigeons now that may not always be so your message to the church of england is you know amplify pigeons yeah big up the pigeons play down the doves yeah exactly and
但鸠，你知道，听起来……我们认为这是理所当然的。那么为什么要这样命名呢？嗯，这种命名在某种程度上只是不幸的命名。我认为鸽子只是名声不好，而且……你知道，它们有区别，有不同类型的鸠，但我认为，在历史上很多提到鸠的地方，它们实际上指的就是鸽子。现在，这可能并不总是如此。你对英国国教会的信息是，你知道，宣扬鸽子，是的，大力宣传鸽子，淡化鸠，是的，完全是这样。
and they and it's they become this symbol of uh peace as well as chastity um and um one of the interesting ways that's used is that they're kind of released and we still see them released you see the kind of doves or white pigeons released, famously at Olympic ceremonies. And this happens in ancient times. It's revived in the modern Olympics. One of the slight tragedies, though, comes in the Seoul Olympics in 1988. It flew into the flame, didn't it? I'm afraid so.
它们成了和平以及贞洁的象征，而……其中一个有趣的使用方式是，它们会被放飞，我们仍然看到它们被放飞，你会看到那种鸠或白鸽被放飞，最著名的是在奥运会开幕式上。这在古代就发生了，并在现代奥运会上得以恢复。然而，其中一个稍显悲剧的时刻发生在1988年首尔奥运会上。它飞进了圣火里，不是吗？恐怕是的。
They didn't fly home, but they just settled on the nearest rocky ledge, which unfortunately was the Olympic flame, which then got turned on and then grilled the pigeons. So essentially in antiquity, there are the two themes. There's the homing pigeon. So as in Noah sending the dove out and it comes back. And then there's this idea of it being monogamous, of being a symbol of lifelong chastity and love. And you can see that both of those, I guess, would, I mean, there's lots of potential there for myth making. Yeah. And you see it in Egyptian mythology, in Greek mythology, you see it in the major modern religious traditions, all of them will use pigeons in different ways. So sometimes associated as well with fertility, again, because of their kind of the way they're bred and also sometimes a sacrifice. So substituted for human sacrifice, sometimes they will they will sacrifice pigeons almost precisely because they're seen as pure. And so it's making this
它们没有飞回家，而是落在了最近的岩石峭壁上，不幸的是，那是奥运圣火，圣火随后被点燃，然后把鸽子烤熟了。所以基本上在古代，有两个主题。一个是信鸽。就像诺亚放飞鸠，它又飞回来一样。另一个是它是一夫一妻制的概念，是终身贞洁和爱情的象征。你可以看到，这两者，我猜，都有很大的神话创造潜力。是的。你在埃及神话、希腊神话中都能看到这一点，你在主要的现代宗教传统中也能看到，所有这些都会以不同的方式使用鸽子。所以有时也与生育力联系在一起，同样是因为它们繁殖的方式，有时也作为祭品。有时用鸽子代替人祭，它们会牺牲鸽子，几乎正是因为它们被视为纯洁的。因此，杀一只鸽子是一种巨大的牺牲。我能提一下我最喜欢的两位古典作家吗？
great sacrifice to kill a pigeon. Could I just mention two of my favourite classical writers? Here we go. We all knew this was coming. Okay, so first Herodotus, first great historian, Greek historian. I don't know if you've come across this, Gordon. There's a story Herodotus says that there were two black doves were sent flying from Thebes in Egypt. And one of them flew to Siwa, which would become the great oracle of Amun that Alexander the Great went to, of course, Dominic. And the other flew to Greece and to Dodona, which became the great oracle of Zeus in northern Greece. And Herodotus has a theory that these were not actually doves, but they were priestesses who'd been kidnapped as slaves and taken away. And he says, the reason for this is to people in Libya and in Greece,
开始了。我们都知道这要来了。好吧，首先是希罗多德，第一位伟大的历史学家，希腊历史学家。我不知道你是否遇到过这个，戈登。希罗多德讲过这样一个故事：两只黑鸽子从埃及底比斯飞出。其中一只飞到了锡瓦，这里后来成为了亚历山大大帝去过的阿蒙大神谕所，当然，多米尼克。另一只飞到了希腊的多多纳，这里成为了希腊北部宙斯的大神谕所。希罗多德有一个理论，这些其实不是鸽子，而是被绑架为奴隶并被带走的 女祭司。他说，之所以这样，是因为对于利比亚人和希腊人来说，
the barbarous language of these Egyptian priestesses must have sounded like doves. And he says, how else to explain the obvious impossibility of a talking dove, the Sandbrookian tone of skepticism, right in the very beginnings of history. The claim of the Dodonians that the dove was black surely signifies that the woman was an Egyptian. So there's Herodotus getting to work on doves. And the other, my other favorite classical writer is Pliny the Elder, who, you know, in his natural history, he's looking at the totality of creation and animals are a crucial part of it and he loves pigeons and there's loads of great stuff about pigeons so he
这些埃及女祭司的野蛮语言听起来一定像鸽子。他说，除此之外，怎么能解释会说话的鸽子这种明显的绝对不可能呢？这就是历史开端处那种桑布鲁克式的怀疑论调。多多纳人声称鸽子是黑色的，这无疑意味着这个女人是埃及人。所以这就是希罗多德对鸽子的研究。另一个——我另一个最喜欢的古典作家是老普林尼，你知道，在他的《自然史》中，他审视了整个创造界，而动物是其中至关重要的一部分，他非常喜欢鸽子，关于鸽子有大量精彩的内容，所以他……
um he says that they would pigeons live to be 30 and sometimes 40 is that true i don't know if that's true um he says that pigeons always lay a male and a female egg the male egg is laid first then the female egg a day later that pigeons um become great pals with peacocks which i think is a lovely idea is that right again i don't know i'm not entirely sure about all of these um and then and then he's i think his most clinching i mean his most fascinating point human teeth contain a kind of poison pliny writes for if you bare your teeth in front of a mirror you will dim its brightness similarly if you bare your teeth at a baby pigeon you will kill it i think those things are both just lies well i don't think they're lies i think possibly i mean possibly not entirely inaccurate but also gordon and coming now to the uses that humans have put pigeons to i know is your great theme um pliny talks about um the fascination
嗯，他说鸽子能活到30岁，有时甚至40岁。这是真的吗？我不知道这是不是真的……他说鸽子总是下一枚雄卵和一枚雌卵。雄卵先产下，一天后产下雌卵。他还说鸽子和孔雀成了好朋友，我觉得这是一个可爱的想法。是这样的吗？同样，我不知道，我并不完全确定所有这些……然后……然后他认为最有说服力的——我的意思是，他最着迷的一点是：人类的牙齿含有一种毒素，普林尼写道，因为如果你在镜子前露出牙齿，你就会削弱它的光泽。同样，如果你对着一只小鸽子露出牙齿，你就会杀死它。我认为这两件事都只是谎言。嗯，我不认为它们是谎言，我觉得可能——嗯，可能并非完全不准确。但也……戈登，现在谈到人类对鸽子的利用，我知道这是你的大主题……普林尼谈到了……
that people in rome have with homing pigeons and he says that they become incredibly valuable and he talks about how in 50 around 50 bc um a single pair of pigeons are sold for 400 denarii which is about twice the annual pay that a legionary is getting. So you're starting to see there that these birds can be incredibly valuable in civilizations and cultures where there is a kind of proper understanding of their homing abilities. So can we come to the homing ability? The way I always think about it, it really is a superpower, you know, because these are creatures which, like a kind of superhero,
罗马人对信鸽的痴迷，他说它们变得非常有价值。他谈到大约公元前50年左右，一对鸽子能卖到45000——抱歉，400 denarii（第纳尔），这大约是一个军团士兵年薪的两倍。所以你开始看到，在那些对鸽子的归巢能力有适当理解的文明和文化中，这些鸟类可以变得极其珍贵。那么我们可以谈谈归巢能力吗？我一直以来的看法是，这真的是一种超能力，你知道的，因为这些生物就像某种超级英雄一样，
they kind of live among us and look normal, and you don't realize that they have this tremendous power i still don't really understand it is that right and like any true kind of superhero story the science behind it is a bit wobbly i mean no one knows how it works but effectively if you imagine if you were taken you know blindfolded and put in the boot of a car and driven 500 miles away and then suddenly let out in a field and told to find your way home without a map, without a phone or anything. You'd be lost. You would have no idea where you were. A pigeon. You can do that. You could take a pigeon, you know, put it in a container, drive it to somewhere it has never been before release it open up the container and it will orient itself and just zoom home as fast as it can how what's its what's its range gordon its range is is hundreds of miles and the trick is with breeding that you can breed them to
它们生活在我们中间，看起来很正常，而你却没有意识到它们拥有这种强大的力量。我还是不太明白，是这样的吗？就像任何真正的超级英雄故事一样，它背后的科学原理有点站不住脚。我的意思是，没有人知道它是如何运作的，但实际上，如果你想象一下，如果你被蒙上双眼，塞进汽车后备箱，车开出500英里，然后突然被放逐到一个田野里，被告知在没有地图、没有手机或任何东西的情况下找到回家的路。你会迷路。你根本不知道自己在哪里。而鸽子。你可以做到这一点。你可以拿一只鸽子，你知道的，把它放进一个容器里，开车把它送到一个它从未去过的地方，放开它，打开容器，它会辨别方向，然后以最快的速度飞回家。它是怎么做到的？它的活动范围是多少，戈登？它的活动范围是数百英里，而诀窍在于通过育种，你可以培育出飞得
go even further and faster and the the definitely definitely cases of at least 600 miles. 600 miles? 600 miles. Yeah, it's amazing, isn't it? And the science behind it is still a bit of a mystery. It is a bit like they have an internal GPS in their head, which allows them to kind of geolocate themselves, you know, perhaps to do with the sun, perhaps to do with the Earth's magnetic field and say, I am here and that way is home and just fly home. And through selective breeding, which is the other aspect of that domestication, which makes it possible to do selective breeding so well with pigeons, you can improve that ability and train it. And the simple reason is pigeons, again, it goes to that kind of warm thing about pigeons. They just love home.
更远更快的品种，而且绝对有至少600英里的案例。600英里？600英里。是的，这太惊人了，不是吗？它背后的科学原理仍然有点神秘。这有点像它们的头部内置了一个GPS，使它们能够定位自己，也许与太阳有关，也许与地球的磁场有关，然后说：“我在那里，那个方向是家”，然后径直飞回家。通过选择性育种——这也是驯化的另一个方面，使得对鸽子进行选择性育种变得如此可行——你可以提高这种能力并对其进行训练。而简单原因在于，鸽子，再次回到那种关于鸽子的温馨事物上。它们就是爱家。
They just love food and they love home. And all they want to do is get home because that's where food is. And so all they can think about when they're released is, how do I get home? I'm the pigeon of the rest of this history. People realise that this is a tremendously useful power you know it's incredibly incredibly valuable so noah recognizes this uh there's a greek poet called anacreon who kind of uses the the dove as a metaphor for um the messages that he wants to send to his beloved and then the beloved will send messages back so that's all fine but with pliny you're starting to get this idea that this might actually i did i mean i don't know what he, is it a sport that he's writing about or is it, does it have military potential?
它们就是爱食物，它们爱家。它们唯一想做的事就是回家，因为那里有食物。所以当它们被释放时，它们脑子里想的全是：“我怎么回家？”我是《历史其余部分》的鸽子。人们意识到这是一种极其有用的力量，你知道的，它具有难以置信的价值。所以诺亚意识到了这一点。有一个名叫阿那克里翁的希腊诗人，他把鸠用作比喻，来表达他想发送给自己心爱之人的信息，然后心爱的人会把信息回传过来。所以这都没问题，但到了普林尼的时代，你开始产生这样一种想法，这实际上可能——我的意思是，我不知道他是怎么想的，这是一项他正在写的体育运动，还是它具有军事潜力？
Because this is the kind of, in your book, this is the kind of the key use that it's put to is in war and in intelligence gathering. And so the earliest use we know about it is about at least kind of 5000 years ago. The Egyptians would use it to warn about flooding. So they take them up the Nile. And if the Nile was flooding, they'd release them. They'd fly home and warn people of that. But then the first time we start to see the kind of use of it militarily does seem to be that we know of, at least, is around the Roman period. Julius Caesar is thought to use them in Gaul to send messages between different parts of his army. At the siege of Medina, the Roman general Decimus Brutus sends messages out of the city by carrier pigeon, which results in reinforcements being sent in to kind of break the siege. So you start to see people realising these are valuable militarily
因为这就是……在你的书中，这是它被应用的关键用途——在战争和情报搜集中。我们所知的最早用途大约是至少5000年前。埃及人会用它们来预警洪水。他们把它们带到尼罗河上游。如果尼罗河发洪水，他们就会放飞它们。它们会飞回家，向人们发出警报。但随后，我们开始看到它在军事上的应用，至少据我们所知，大约是在罗马时期。尤利乌斯·恺撒被认为在高卢使用它们在军队的不同部分之间传递信息。在梅代纳围城战中，罗马将军德西穆斯·布鲁图斯用信鸽将信息传出城外，从而促使增援部队被派往城内以打破围城。所以你开始看到人们意识到这些在军事上很有价值，
as well as in everyday life. So as well as sending messages about the results of the Olympics, which is thought to happen in classical times. You see this military use. A basic question, Gordon. I'm a Roman general. I have a pigeon. I want to send him to my lieutenant to ask for reinforcements or whatever. I mean, obviously, I tie the message to the pigeon's egg. How does the pigeon know
在日常生活中也是如此。正如发送关于奥运会结果的信息一样——这被认为发生在古典时期。你看到了这种军事用途。一个基础问题，戈登。我是一名罗马将军。我有一只鸽子。我想把它送给我的副官去请求增援或别的什么。显然，我把信息绑在鸽子的……腿上。鸽子怎么知道
where to go? If I say, please go to the barracks of the Third Legion or whatever. I mean, how does the pigeon, how have they, they must have obviously done something, but what have they done? So all the pigeon will know is it goes to its home i mean in modern terms a loft but a home the home where it which it associates with its food so the trick is if you're training these pigeons you slowly release them further and further away but always have the food there for them to return to and then you slowly can extend the range but it will always associate that one home as food so it's difficult so what's hard is it's hard to use them in a very mobile way because they will always tend to go back to the same place right if they're on campaign you don't want the pigeon to
该去哪里？如果我说，请去第三军团的营房什么的。我的意思是，鸽子怎么……它们肯定做过什么，但它们做了什么？所以鸽子唯一知道的是它要回它的家。用现代术语来说，就是一个鸽舍，但也就是它与食物联系在一起的那个家。所以诀窍是，如果你在训练这些鸽子，你慢慢地把它们带得越来越远放飞，但总是把食物放在那里等它们返回，然后你可以慢慢扩大范围，但它总是会把那个家与食物联系起来。所以这很困难……难点在于，很难以一种非常灵活的方式使用它们，因为它们总是倾向于回到同一个地方，对吧？如果它们在打仗，你可不想让鸽子
go back to rome yeah no but you can start training them from very young so within So within a couple of months, you could have one which is flying home. See, right, right, right. So you could have a kind of headquarters or a base to which they will fly and know that and then use that as your form of communication. So that kind of military use comes in then. And then you see it right through history. I mean, this use for kind of pigeon post. And it's not just in the Western world. You see it in China. There's a very active pigeon post between, I think, Baghdad and Cairo in the 12th century. Genghis Khan used pigeons to communicate over those long distances so it's used kind of throughout this period as the kind of one of the standard means of communication effectively one other logistical question let's talk about the speed so if i'm in baghdad and i want to send a message to cairo obviously that's going to take i know they they probably have tremendous roads in the abbasid
飞回罗马。是的，没错，但你可以从它们很小的时候开始训练。所以几个月内，你就能养出一只能飞回家的鸽子。看，对，对，对。所以你可以有一个总部或基地，它们会飞向那里并认得那个地方，然后将其作为你的通信形式。这种军事用途就是这样引入的。然后你会在整个历史中看到它。我的意思是，这种用于信鸽邮递的用途。而且不仅在西方世界。你在中国也能看到。在12世纪的巴格达和开罗之间，有一个非常活跃的信鸽邮政系统。成吉思汗使用鸽子在这些长距离之间进行通信，所以在整个这一时期，它都被用作标准的通信手段之一。还有一个后勤问题，我们来谈谈速度。如果我在巴格达，我想给开罗发一条消息，显然这需要……我知道阿拔斯王朝可能拥有极好的公路网，
caliphate tom you'll know more about this than me. Obviously, the Persians had their famous kind of highways and stuff. But can the pigeon dramatically outpace a team of horsemen or something? Would you say, Gordon? 60 miles an hour is a good speed for a pigeon can do. That is pretty dramatic. Which is pretty good, you know, and for a sustained period. They don't like to fly at night, and they kind of tend to take particular routes. But, you know, you can… But a pigeon could fly for six hours?
托姆，你对此比我了解得更多。显然，波斯人有他们著名的公路之类的东西。但是鸽子能大大超越一队骑马的人或其他什么吗？你会这么说吗，戈登？时速60英里是鸽子能达到的好速度。这相当惊人。相当不错，你知道的，而且能够持续一段时间。它们不喜欢在夜间飞行，而且它们往往会走特定的路线。但是，你知道，你可以……但是鸽子可以飞行六个小时吗？
Yeah. At 60 miles an hour? Yeah, exactly. So they can cover hundreds of miles in a day, in a day's flight. Yeah, that's incredible. So particularly, you know, you can imagine it's particularly if you're cut off. So that, you know, if you're in a campaign or you're somewhere which is remote, and the territory between you is, you know, held by an opponent or dangerous or difficult,
是的。以时速60英里？是的，完全可以。所以它们在一天内，在当天的飞行中就能飞越数百英里。是的，这太不可思议了。所以尤其是，你可以想象，特别是如果你被切断了联系。所以，你知道，如果你在进行战役，或者你在一个偏远的地方，你和外界之间的领土被对手占据，或者很危险、很困难，
if you can allow a pigeon to take that journey rather than trying to do it on horseback or foot. It's much easier. Yeah. So this is something that people are doing throughout history and it carries on into the modern period. So in modern periods of modern warfare. Yeah. And back to the kind of modern period, if you hit the 19th century, to Dominic's question about speed, 1850, the birth of the Reuters news agency comes with a pigeon. So Julius Reuters in Belgium flies pigeons to carry news and stock prices between Brussels and Germany because it's faster than any other means. So you can see even in that period, you know, the telegraph is slowly emerging, but the pigeon is still pretty useful. And that's where kind of Reuters comes from. You also start to the 19th century, I think, is almost where it becomes in the kind of popular consciousness.
如果你能让鸽子完成这段旅程，而不是试图骑马或步行。这要容易得多。是的。所以这是人们贯穿整个历史一直在做的事情，并且它一直延续到现代。所以在现代战争时期。是的。回到现代时期，如果你进入19世纪，对于多米尼克关于速度的问题，1850年，路透社的诞生伴随着一只鸽子。因此，比利时的朱利叶斯·路透（Julius Reuter）用鸽子在布鲁塞尔和德国之间传递新闻和股票价格，因为这比任何其他方式都快。所以你可以看到，即使在那个时期，你知道，电报正在慢慢兴起，但鸽子仍然相当有用。这就是路透社的来源。你还会看到19世纪，我认为这几乎是它进入大众意识的时期。
Before then, it's military commanders. It's often aristocrats who are the aristocracy breed pigeons, often for sport and for show kind of in India and in other places as well. They enter the popular consciousness a bit more in that late 19th century period. The siege of Paris is very important because Paris under siege 1870, a couple of million messages are thought to come out through pigeons. And pigeons are often taken in on hot air balloons, weirdly, and delivered. People will fill in their messages, release the pigeons, and they fly out. And it allows people to know what's going on.
在此之前，它是军事指挥官的工具。通常是贵族——在印度和其他地方，贵族们经常为了运动和展览而繁育鸽子。在19世纪末的那个时期，它们更多地进入了大众意识。巴黎围城战非常重要，因为1870年被围困的巴黎，据信有数百万条消息通过鸽子传递出去。而且鸽子经常被奇怪地用热气球带进去并交付。人们会填写他们的信息，放飞鸽子，它们就会飞出去。这让人们知道发生了什么。
So that also is a period where you see people understand the kind of value of it. And they become something people are kind of talking about. And pigeon racing starts to emerge as a sport particularly in belgium but in other countries as well in that late 19th century period and then you get to the kind of 20th century when they are really important in wartime gordon could i just mention um on the discord uh which um we have for the uh rest of history members uh there's a message from andrew h who says i'm a sub-editor at reuters so i have to tell you that our founder Baron Julius Reuter used pigeons to deliver stock market prices in 1850 so just
所以这也是一个你看到人们理解其价值的时期。它们成为人们谈论的事物。赛鸽运动开始作为一项体育运动兴起，特别是在比利时，但在19世纪末的其他国家也是如此。然后你就进入了20世纪，那时它们在战时变得非常重要。戈登，我能提一下……在我们的Discord上——我们为《历史其余部分》的会员建立的那个——有一条来自安德鲁·H（Andrew H）的消息，他说：“我是路透社的一名副主编，所以我不得不告诉你，我们的创始人朱利叶斯·路透男爵在1850年使用鸽子来传递股市价格。”所以这只是
backing up what you said there very good also my favorite historical Reuters sub-editing fact that there's a spelling mistake on the Baron's grave in West Norwood Cemetery and a small plaque nearby correcting the typo so that has nothing to do with pigeons but I just thought I'd I'd mention that because it's a sweet fact so so we come to we come to the first world war and i guess the most famous pigeon in the first world war is speckled jim we've had a number of questions so for those who haven't seen it this is blackadder goes forth um uh comedy show set in the uh. And Edmund Blackadder, played by Rowan Atkinson, shoots a pigeon,
支持了你刚才所说的，非常好。这也是我最喜欢的路透社历史副主编趣闻：西诺伍德公墓（West Norwood Cemetery）男爵的墓碑上有一个拼写错误，附近有一块小小的牌匾纠正了这个拼写错误。这与鸽子毫无关系，但我只是觉得我应该提一下，因为这是一个很可爱的趣闻。所以我们来到了第一次世界大战，我猜一战中最著名的鸽子是“斑点吉姆”（Speckled Jim）。我们收到了很多问题。所以对于那些没看过的人来说，这是《黑爵士第四季》……一部以……为背景的喜剧节目。由罗温·阿金森（Rowan Atkinson）扮演的埃德蒙·黑爵士（Edmund Blackadder）射杀了一只鸽子，
which is owned by Stephen Fry, a.k.a. General Melchett, who is unbelievably upset by this and gets him sentenced to be shot by a firing squad for it. And we have a question from Michael Taylor.
这只鸽子属于斯蒂芬·弗fry（Stephen Fry），也就是梅尔切特将军（General Melchett）。梅尔切特将军对此感到无比难过，并因此判处黑爵士被行刑队枪决。我们收到了来自迈克尔·泰勒（Michael Taylor）的一个问题。
Was shooting pigeons such as Speckled Jim truly a capital offence in the trenches? Well, the pigeons were certainly shot and snipers would go after them. Now, whether it was a capital offence in the trenches, I'm not sure. I could imagine quite a few people like Blackadder would have, if you're hungry, a pigeon is a very tempting thing,
在战壕里射杀像“斑点吉姆”这样的鸽子真的是一项死罪吗？嗯，鸽子确实被射杀过，狙击手也会追捕它们。至于这在战壕里是不是死罪，我不太确定。我可以想象，像黑爵士这样的人会有不少……如果你饿了，鸽子是一个非常诱人的东西，
which is what Blackadder does, unfortunately. It's a speckled gin, which it turns out is General Melchett's prize, famous, favourite pigeon. But actually, I'm not sure people would have shot them so easily because they really did rely on them. And they used them in the First World War in a fascinating way. And one of my favourite quotes, which I'll just briefly read, which I think if I could read it in a general metal chip voice, I would, but it's, if it became necessarily immediately to discard every line and method of communications used on the front except one, and if it were left to me to select that one method, I should unhesitatingly choose the pigeons. This is Major General Fowler, Chief of Signals and Communications in the British Army.
这也是黑爵士不幸做的事。那是“斑点吉姆”，结果证明它是梅尔切特将军的珍爱、著名、最喜欢的鸽子。但实际上，我不确定人们会那么容易地射杀它们，因为他们确实非常依赖它们。他们在第一次世界大战中以一种非常引人入胜的方式使用了它们。我最喜欢的名言之一，我将简短地朗读一下，我想如果我能用梅尔切特将军的声音来读它就好了，但它是这样的：“如果前线使用的每一条和每一种通信线路和方法，除了一种之外，现在都必须立即废弃，并且如果让我来选择那一种方法，我会毫不犹豫地选择鸽子。”这是英国陆军信号与通信局局长福勒少将（Major General Fowler）说的。
When the battle rages and everything gives way to barrage and machine gun fire, to say nothing of gas attacks and bombings, it is to the pigeon that we go for sucker. There must have been particular heroic pigeons, but am I right in thinking, is there one that stands out for you? Oh, there is for me. This is one of my favourites, Cher Ami. So this is the US Army's 77th Division, becomes known as the Lost Battalion. It becomes trapped effectively behind enemy lines in a forest. And then its own side begins to shell it because they don't know they're there. I know. And so they think we've got to get a message out to our own side to say, to stop this. They've got three pigeons. First pigeon, they write a message saying, you know, we're here.
当战斗正酣，一切都让位于弹幕和机枪扫射，更不用说毒气袭击和轰炸时，我们寻求援助的对象就是鸽子。一定有特别英勇的鸽子，但我的理解对吗，有没有哪一只是对你来说最突出的？哦，对我有。这是我最喜欢的之一：谢阿米（Cher Ami）。这是美国陆军第77师，被称为“迷失营”（Lost Battalion）。它实际上被困在了森林里的敌后。然后它自己人开始炮轰它，因为他们不知道他们在那儿。我知道。所以他们想，我们必须给自己的军队发个消息，说……去阻止这个。他们有三只鸽子。第一只鸽子，他们写了一张纸条，上面写着：“你知道，我们在这儿。
Stop the shelling. For heaven's sake, stop it. First pigeon, they write a message saying, you know, we're here. Stop the shelling, for heaven's sake, stop it. First pigeon, they release into the air, shot by a German sniper. Second pigeon, another message, released into the air, shot by a German. Third pigeon, last pigeon, their last hope effectively of survival, Cher Ami, released into the air, shot, but it flies on. Cher Ami keeps going despite being terribly wounded, terribly wounded, makes it back to base in about half an hour or so. With the message, the shelling stopped and the lost battalion is saved. And Jeremy is lauded as this great prigion, Croix de Guerre from the war. It loses its leg and is blinded, but survives the journey home
停止炮看在老天的份上，停下来。”第一只鸽子，他们把它放飞到空中，被德国狙击手击中了。第二只鸽子，又一张纸条，放飞到空中，被德国人击中了。第三只鸽子，最后一只鸽子，实际上是他们生存的最后希望，谢阿米，被放飞到空中，中弹了，但它继续飞。谢阿米顶着重伤继续前进，身受重伤，在大约半小时左右回到了基地。带着消息，炮击停止了，迷失营获救了。而谢阿米被誉为这只伟大的鸽子，获得了战争十字勋章（Croix de Guerre）。它失去了一条腿并且失明了，但它在回家之旅中存活了下来，
and is then, when it dies soon afterwards, stuffed. And you can see it in the Smithsonian Museum in Washington. Oh, I thought you were going to say it gets a kind of military funeral and buried with full honours. I didn't think it would be stuffed. So there is a question from Al Akfar who asks, what medals have pigeons received? So you've got the Croix de Guerre. Yeah, Croix de Guerre.
并且在不久后死后被做成了标本。你可以在华盛顿的史密森尼博物馆看到它。哦，我还以为你会说它会获得某种军事葬礼并以最高荣誉安葬呢。我没想到它会被做成标本。所以阿尔·阿克法（Al Akfar）有一个问题，他问：鸽子获得过什么勋章？所以你有战争十字勋章。是的，战争十字勋章。
And then in the Second World War, which we can come to, the Dickin Medal, which is, you know, very important. So, Gordon, I think we should take a break here because, Gordon, the Second World world war that really is the kind of the gateway for you wasn't it into your fascination with pigeons that's my gateway drug your gateway drug and this is this was the subject of your your great book operation columba so let's take a break now and when we come back maybe you could tell us the story of operation columba i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
然后在第二次世界大战中，我们可以谈到这一点，迪金勋章（Dickin Medal），你知道，这非常重要。所以，戈登，我想我们应该在这里休息一下，因为，戈登，第二次世界大战，那确实是你对鸽子产生迷恋的门户，不是吗？那是我的入门毒品，你的入门毒品，这也是你的伟大著作《科伦巴行动》的主题。所以我们现在休息一下，等我们回来时，也许你可以给我们讲讲《科伦巴行动》的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
八卦以及在我们的问答环节中拉开娱乐界帷幕并告诉你这一切如何运作的节目。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The BBC's Gordon Carrera is manfully succeeding in his great enterprise of persuading me and the listening public of the Western world that nothing has mattered more in human history than the humble pigeon or rock dove, as I learned, I should now think of it.
如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。BBC的戈登·卡雷拉正在英勇地成功完成他的伟大事业，说服我和西方世界的听众：在人类历史上，没有什么比谦逊的鸽子——或者正如我所学到的，我现在应该称之为岩鸽——更重要的了。
So Gordon, we had the First World War and the tremendous story of Cher Ami, but really your interest began with the Second World War with Operation Columba. Because obviously we think of the Second World War as radar Columba. Because obviously, we think of the Second World War as radar, suburb U-boats, a very technologically advanced conflict. But pigeons played an underappreciated role in the Second World War, didn't they? Absolutely. And thousands of them. And one of the interesting things, it was part of the People's War as well, because pigeons have become a big sport. There were about 70,000 pigeon lofts by the time you get to the start of the Second World War.
所以，戈登，我们讲了第一次世界大战和谢阿米（Cher Ami）的动人故事，但实际上你的兴趣始于第二次世界大战的《科伦巴行动》（Operation Columba）。因为显然我们认为二战是雷达、U型潜艇、一个技术高度先进的冲突。但在二战中，鸽子扮演了一个被低估的角色，不是吗？绝对是的。成千上万只。其中一个有趣的事情是，这也是“人民战争”（People's War）的一部分，因为赛鸽已经变成了一项大型运动。到二战开始时，大约有70,000个鸽舍。
Homing pigeons who were being used for sport, real part of working class culture, actually, at that time. It's really interesting, kind of partly lost, but not entirely. It's still there. But, you know, it's referred to at the time as the kind of as the poor man's racehorse. You know, if you might have wanted to, you know, you might have dreamt of breeding a horse and being able to race it and win some money. Well, you couldn't afford to do that if you're a working class, but you could breed those pigeons in your loft. So it's become a huge sport. And at the start of the war, there is this decision to kind of tap into this. And it's because of a particular intelligence requirement. Europe has been occupied, the kind of traditional intelligence networks for MI6, for instance, have collapsed at the start of the war. And as a result, they're desperate to understand what is going on inside occupied France, the Low Countries, and to get a feel for what's happening. And so this intelligence operation is proposed,
用于比赛的信鸽在当时实际上是工人阶级文化的一个真正部分。这真的很有趣，某种程度上已经失落，但并非完全如此。它仍然存在。但是，你知道，当时它被称为“穷人的赛马”。你知道，如果你可能想要，你知道，你可能梦想培育一匹马并能够让它参赛并赢得一些奖金。好吧，如果你是工人阶级，你负担不起这样做，但你可以在你的鸽舍里培育那些鸽子。所以它变成了一项巨大的运动。在战争开始时，有一个决定去挖掘利用这一点。这是因为一个特定的情报需求。欧洲被占领了，军情六处（MI6）等传统的谍报网络在战争爆发时已经崩溃。因此，他们迫切想要了解被占领的法国、低地国家内部正在发生的事情，并了解情况。因此，这项情报行动被提议了，
and it comes out through a very obscure branch of British intelligence. You've heard of mi5 you've heard of mi6 this is mi14 subsection d which runs the special continental pigeon service and they decide that what you can do is drop pigeons effectively randomly behind enemy lines by flying over it through the RAF who are flying and dropping in special agents. You drop pigeons in canisters and attached to the canisters is a note saying, this is a pigeon from Britain. And they often put a copy of a resistance newspaper, sometimes the Daily Mail with it to prove it had come from Britain. Dominic Tom, What a choice.
它来自英国情报部门的一个非常不起眼的部门。你听说过军情五处（MI5），你听说过军情六处（MI6），这是运行特殊大陆信鸽服务的军情十四处D子处（MI14 subsection d）。他们决定，你可以做的是通过皇家空军（RAF）飞越敌后并投放特工时，将鸽子实际上随机地投放在敌后。你把鸽子装在圆筒里，圆筒上附有一张纸条，上面写着：“这是一只来自英国的鸽子。”他们经常在里面放一份抵抗运动报纸的复印件，有时是《每日邮报》，以证明它是从英国来的。多米尼克，托姆，这选择真绝啊。
And a questionnaire. And the questionnaire was, what are the Germans doing in your area? What are the German troop deployments? Have they been on the move? What's German morale like? What's the food situation? Even what's the reception of the BBC? Because they were kind of interested in knowing that.
还有一份问卷。问卷的内容是：德国人在你们地区在做什么？德国军队部署情况如何？他们一直在调动吗？德国人的士气如何？食物情况怎么样？甚至对BBC的接收情况如何？因为他们对了解这些很感兴趣。
A series of kind of questions for people to gather intelligence from ordinary people in occupied Europe. And they relied on these pigeons being effectively donated by ordinary pigeon fanciers in Britain, who would give their pigeons to the army and to MI-14D, and who would then drop them through the RAF and then wait and see what they got back on return flights. What do they get back? Well, they get back this, you know, and I found this file in the National Archives, which full of these pink slips and reading them is really powerful because they're just from ordinary people in rural France, particularly also Belgium, the Netherlands. And they range from people going, you know, not much, not much to see here, but please come and liberate us soon to to talk about the food supply to rich intelligence about what's going on in their area. There's one particular message which I kind of got obsessed
这是一系列针对被占领欧洲普通民众的问题，旨在从中搜集情报。英国的普通信鸽爱好者自愿把信鸽捐献给军队和军情五处下属的MI-14D，军队通过英国皇家空军将信鸽空投出去，然后等待并观察回飞的信鸽能带回什么。它们能带回什么呢？其实就是这些东西，你知道的。我在国家档案馆里发现了这个档案袋，里面装满了这种粉红色的便条。读这些便条真的很有震撼力，因为它们仅仅来自法国乡村、尤其是比利时和荷兰的普通老百姓。他们的信件内容五花八门，有的人写着“这里没什么特别情况，但请赶快来解放我们吧”，有的人谈论食品供应，还有人提供有关当地德军活动的丰富情报。其中有一条特殊的讯息，我甚至有点着迷了
by, which was message 37, which came from Belgium and had this amazing amount of detail. And if you imagine it had to be fitted on a piece of paper about the size of a large postage stamp, which could then go into a tube and fit around a pigeon's leg. And yet it produced about a dozen pages of intelligence because someone had written in the most tiny way. It was actually a Catholic priest who'd learnt calligraphy while a missionary in China to write in huge detail intelligence about German deployments and where German headquarters were. And in the archives, you know, this message gets shown to Churchill and Churchill is shown that message personally. And, you know, in a way, I found that fascinating because Churchill himself wouldn't, you know, he didn't need to know that specific piece of intelligence. You know, that's not his job. So why was he shown it? Well, the answer was it embodied that spirit of resistance, which Churchill so believed in and so wanted to foster in Europe. And this was a sign that there were people there in occupied Europe who were willing to risk their lives by sending messages back to Britain through a pigeon with intelligence because they wanted to resist. So it was this powerful bond was created through the pigeon
那就是第37号讯息，它来自比利时，包含了极其惊人的细节。你可以想象一下，它必须被塞进一张大约只有大邮票大小的纸条里，然后装进一个管子，绑在鸽子的腿上。然而，它却提供了大约十几页的情报，因为有人用极其微小的字迹写下了这些内容。这其实是一位天主教神父，他在中国传教时学会了书法，从而能够用极度详尽的笔触记录下德军的调动情况以及德国指挥部的所在地。在档案馆里，你知道的，这个讯息被拿给丘吉尔看，丘吉尔是亲自过目了这条讯息的。从某种程度上说，我觉得这非常迷人，因为丘吉尔本人其实并不需要知道那些具体的情报细节，那不是他的工作。那么，为什么要把这个给他看呢？答案是，它体现了那种反抗精神，而丘吉尔对这种精神深信不疑，也极力想在欧洲培育这种精神。这是一个信号，表明在被占领的欧洲，有人愿意通过鸽子将情报发回英国，冒着生命危险传递信息，因为他们渴望反抗。因此，通过这只鸽子，
between Britain and people in occupied Europe, particularly in that early stage of the war. But also, Gordon, presumably because it kind of shows the can-do spirit, the innovative qualities that Churchill was really into, wasn't it? I mean, he was kind of obsessed with coming up with weird wh he likes a wheeze, doesn't he? He likes a wheeze and a clever intelligence operation. And what's interesting is even the kind of scientific bods in British intelligence. So R.V. Jones, who's the famous figure involved in MI6 and the Air Ministry, realises he can use these pigeons. So he asks for a question on this questionnaire about,
英国与被占领欧洲的人民之间建立了一种强有力的纽带，特别是在战争的早期阶段。但是戈登，这大概也是因为这展现了一种“能做到”的精神，以及丘吉尔非常欣赏的创新特质，对吧？我的意思是，他有点痴迷于想出各种古怪的点子，他喜欢好点子，不是吗？他喜欢好点子和聪明的谍报行动。有趣的是，甚至连英国情报部门里那些搞科学的专家也这么认为。比如大卫·琼斯（R.V. Jones），他是参与军情六处和空军部的著名人物，他意识到自己可以利用这些鸽子。因此，他在调查问卷里加入了一个问题，
have you seen any kind of strange structures with rotating features? And what he's looking for are German radar stations. And he realises that people will spot something strange. They won't know what it is, but they're so unusual that they will be able to identify these radar stations, often hidden in rural locations, which is the kind of places these pigeons normally get dropped. And a number of German radar stations are spotted purely
问：“你们有没有看到任何带有旋转特征的奇怪建筑？”他寻找的是德国的雷达站。他意识到人们会发现一些奇怪的东西。他们可能不知道那是什么，但因为这些东西太不寻常了，他们将能够识别出这些通常隐藏在乡村地点的雷达站，而乡村正是这些鸽子通常被空投的地方。许多德国雷达站正是纯粹
thanks to Operation Columba and then destroyed, which protects RAF planes. And the same, actually, with V1 and V2 launch sites. Again, you know, these very modern weapons of war are spotted, thanks to intelligence, which is brought back through the pigeons. And Gordon, are the Germans doing the same? Are they using pigeons? Yes. So they actually, in true German style, are far more organised about their pigeon use than the kind of slightly haphazard British volunteer operation. But one of the fun stories of the war is, so early on, there's this worry that
依靠“哥伦比亚行动”（Operation Columba）被发现，随后被摧毁，从而保护了英国皇家空军的飞机。V1和V2发射场的情况其实也是如此。同样，你知道的，这些非常现代的战争武器被发现，要归功于通过鸽子带回的情报。戈登，德国人也在这么做吗？他们也在使用鸽子吗？是的。因此，他们实际上表现出真正德国式的作风，对鸽子的使用远比英国这种略显杂乱的志愿者行动要更有组织性。不过，战争中有一个有趣的笑话，那就是在早期，人们担心
British Columba pigeons and other pigeons being used in the war are going to be killed by peregrine falcons on the coast. and so they decide that to protect the intelligence coming in from the birds they're gonna have to kill the peregrine falcons and so mi5 sets up one of the few units i've ever discovered which does have a license to kill which is the falcon destruction unit and its job which is the falcon destruction unit is five guys who go around in a big american packard car with a with a caravan on the back and go around the cliffs of britain killing falcons basically and their job is to protect the pigeons unfortunately one falls off a cliff to his death but it's so it's it's a kind of tragic comic story but then in in that piece of kind of absurdity
英国的“哥伦比亚”信鸽以及战争中使用的其他信鸽，会在海岸边被游隼捕杀。因此他们决定，为了保护鸟类带回的情报，他们不得不杀掉这些游隼。于是军情五处成立了极少数我发现的拥有“杀戮执照”的单位之一——“游隼消灭分队”（Falcon Destruction Unit）。它的职责——这个游隼消灭分队由五个人组成，他们开着一辆挂着拖挂式房车的大型美国帕卡德汽车，在英国的悬崖边巡视，基本上就是去杀游隼。他们的工作是保护信鸽。不幸的是，其中一个人从悬崖上摔下去身亡了。所以这是一个带有悲喜剧色彩的故事。但随后，在那种荒诞的事件中，
which could only be kind of the British, you know, wartime intelligence service, they then suddenly get worried at MI5 that actually the Germans might be sending pigeons out of Britain, and that they might be using pigeons for undercover agents in Britain to send back intelligence for Germany. So they suddenly realise, particularly they spot some pigeons flying. Nazi pigeons. Nazi pigeons flying fast over the Silly Isles towards Europe. And they're like, Nazi pigeons, we've got to stop them. So in a...
这大概也只有英国的战时情报机构才做得出来。军情五处突然开始担心，德国人实际上可能会从英国放出信鸽，并且他们可能会利用信鸽让潜伏在英国的间谍向德国发回情报。所以他们突然意识到，特别是他们发现一些鸽子在飞。纳粹鸽子。纳粹鸽子正快速飞过锡利群岛飞往欧洲。他们当时就想：“纳粹鸽子，我们必须阻止它们！”于是，在一个……
How do you identify a Nazi pigeon? I've got swastikas. Just to be clear. They're doing salutes while they're flying. That's a good question. So in one of those fantastic wartime reversals from having a Falcon destruction unit, they then decide they need a Falcon unit to hunt Nazi pigeons and set one up and get someone who has got a Peregrine Falcon trained to hunt Nazi pigeons.
你怎么识别一只纳粹鸽子？它带着卐字标志。为了以防万一，它们在飞的时候还在行纳粹礼。这是个好问题。所以，在战时那些奇妙的反转之一中，他们从拥有一个游隼消灭分队，突然决定他们需要一个游隼分队来猎杀纳粹鸽子，于是组建了一个，并找了一个训练有素、会猎杀纳粹鸽子的游隼来的人。
And this team from MI5 goes onto the Scilly Isles in the summer and they sit on the golf course of the Scilly Isles with a falcon on their wrist, as you might have seen, ready to hunt pigeons. And they kill pigeons. But the only pigeons they kill are plucky British pigeons. So they never find a Nazi pigeon? Not a single Nazi pigeon. There must be some way they could have done a coup or test
这个来自军情五处的团队在夏天前往锡利群岛，他们坐在锡利群岛的高尔夫球场上，手腕上停着一只游隼，正如你可能想象的那样，准备猎杀鸽子。他们确实杀死了鸽子。但他们杀死的唯一鸽子却是勇敢的英国鸽子。所以他们从来没有找到过纳粹鸽子？一只纳粹鸽子都没有。一定有什么方法可以让他们做个测试，
to see if their coup had got a German accent, a German-accented pigeon. No swastikas on the pigeon, no friend or foe identifier on the pigeon. So it's not the most successful wartime operation, it's fair to say, but emblematic of the realities of war. And Gordon, does this division of MI5 still exist? We wouldn't know, would we, Tom? If it was, Tom. I think it was B13C of MI5.
看看他们的“俘虏”有没有德国口音，这是一只带有德国口音的鸽子吗？鸽子上没有卐字标志，也没有敌我识别标志。所以很难说这是一次最成功的战时行动，但它确实是战争现实的象征。戈登，军情五处的这个部门现在还存在吗？我们不会知道的，对吧，汤姆？如果它真的存在的话，汤姆。我想它是军情五处的B13C科。
It might secretly still be going on. It might still be, yeah. But there are other heroic pigeons, aren't there? So there's a pigeon, I believe, called Winky ah yes he's a great hero of the second world war yeah because they also use them on the rf gives pigeons to planes particularly going over the sea in case they crash in case they ditch um and the radios don't work or there's a problem then you release a pigeon with your coordinates and And Winky is a very famous case because the plane tries to radio where it is, it ditches. Winky actually gets free without a message, flies home, but covered in oil from the ditching.
它可能还在秘密运作。它可能还在，是的。但还有其他英雄鸽子，对吧？所以有一只鸽子，我相信叫“温基”（Winky）。啊是的，他是第二次世界大战的伟大英雄，是的。因为他们还把鸽子用在皇家空军上，把鸽子发给飞机，特别是那些飞越海洋的飞机，以防它们坠毁，以防它们迫降，呃，如果电台坏了或者出了问题，你就可以放飞一只载有你坐标的鸽子。温基是一个非常著名的案例，因为飞机试图用无线电报告它在哪里时坠毁了。温基实际上没有带任何信息就挣脱了，飞回家里，但身上沾满了迫降时的油污。
And so the loft owner and the RAF work out that this is a pigeon from the plane that ditched. And they work out, based on the speed with which it flew, roughly where that plane might be and then locate the plane and save the crew in their dinghy. That's a good story. Does Winky get a medal? Winky is one of those who is heavily decorated. And I think he's giving a big dinner at the RAA. He's winking. He's winking.
因此，鸽舍主人和皇家空军弄清楚这是一只来自迫降飞机的信鸽。根据它飞行的速度，他们大致计算出那架飞机可能在哪里，然后定位了飞机，并在救生艇上救出了机组人员。这是一个好故事。温基得到勋章了吗？温基是那些获得大量勋章的人之一。而且我认为他在皇家空军享用了一场盛大的晚宴。他在眨眼。他在眨眼。
And that's why he's called Winky. But the thought is he's actually so exhausted still. He's never recovered from his flight. That's why he's winking. If I was a pigeon, I'd be very suspicious of being invited to a dinner at an RAA. Wouldn't you? I'd be very angry. I'd want to see the menu before.
这就是为什么他叫“温基”。但大家的想法是，其实他还是太累了。他从未从那次飞行中恢复过来。这就是为什么他在眨眼。如果我是一只鸽子，对于被邀请去参加皇家空军的晚宴，我会非常怀疑。你不会吗？我会非常生气。我得在去之前先看看菜单。
I'm afraid that's what happens to lots of the Columba pigeons. You know, they're dropped in the French countryside and hungry French, French farmers roast them with peas. Oh, that's broad. A pigeon pitches up with a copy of the Daily Mail. And the first thing the French do is eat it.
恐怕这就是许多“哥伦比亚”信鸽的下场。你知道的，它们被空投到法国乡村，饥饿的法国农夫把它们和豌豆一起烤着吃。哦，这太粗鲁了。一只鸽子带着一份《每日邮报》飞来，法国人做的第一件事就是把它吃掉。
Confirming all your darker suspicions. So Gordon, after the Second World War, do pigeons continue to have any role in intelligence or not? Well, so after the war, there is this, again, when I went through the National Archives, the things you find at Kew, but was a file about the Joint Intelligence Committee subcommittee on pigeons, whose minutes I read studiously, in which there is quite a serious debate about, you know, whether pigeons, whether a pigeon research capability should be kept. And they look at things, for instance, about whether pigeons have a role in the atomic age. So could they fly through, you know, kind of clouds of radioactivity and still, would that affect their ability? The signs are in Britain that they stop after the Second World War. But
这证实了你所有的黑暗猜想。那么戈登，第二次世界大战后，信鸽在情报工作中是否继续发挥任何作用？嗯，战后确实有这样一档事。当我翻阅国家档案馆时，在邱园（Kew）发现的东西中，有一份关于联合情报委员会信鸽小组委员会的档案，我认真地阅读了它的会议记录。其中有一场相当严肃的辩论，讨论信鸽——是否应该保留信鸽的研究能力。他们研究了一些问题，例如信鸽在原子时代是否还能发挥作用。比如它们能否穿过放射性云层，这是否会影响它们的能力？英国的迹象表明，他们在二战后停止了这一做法。但是
fascinatingly, in the US, I was lucky enough, I was interviewing for the BBC, the director of the CIA a few years ago, and I have a museum in the CIA of kind of artifacts. And I was fascinated to see one of the artifacts they have is a stuffed pigeon with a tiny camera on its chest. And it turns out what they did was drop these pigeons over the Soviet Union or the Eastern Bloc. And the camera had a kind of automatic shutter. so it would just snap pictures as it flew back from where it was to its home. One of the things, until recently, there was a sign when you looked this up on the CIA website, it said, details of spy pigeon missions are still classified. Oh, fantastic. That's great. Which I love. So one kind of issue I just wanted to raise
令人着迷的是，在美国，我很幸运，几年前我为BBC采访了中情局局长，中情局里有一个陈列文物的博物馆。我很着迷地看到他们收藏的文物之一是一只胸前带着微型相机的标本鸽。事实证明，他们所做的是将这些鸽子空投到苏联或东欧上空。相机的快门是一种自动的，所以当它从放飞地点飞回家的途中，就会一路抓拍照片。直到最近，当你访问中情局网站查询这个内容时，上面还有一个标志，写着：“间谍鸽任务的细节仍然属于机密。”哦，太棒了！这太棒了。我太喜欢这个了。所以我想提出的一个问题是
is we kind of reached the modern era, which, you know, I know this is a history podcast, but a kind of current national security concern that I have, which is what I call the pigeon gap. And Dominic will be familiar about the missile gap. The missile gap. I've never heard of the pigeon gap. Which Kennedy obviously campaigned.
我们进入了现代，虽然我知道这是一个历史播客，但我有一个当前的国家安全担忧，我称之为“信鸽鸿沟”（pigeon gap）。多米尼克会对“导弹鸿沟”很熟悉。导弹鸿沟。我从来没听说过信鸽鸿沟。肯尼迪显然曾为此竞选过。
My concern about the pigeon gap came when I read this article that the Chinese People's Liberation Army in recent years was training 10,000 carrier pigeons. And the reason was that they were concerned that in the event of some kind of cyber attack, which took out their communications, they could then rely on pigeons. And it got me worried and wondering, you know, whether we are pigeon prepared as a nation, or is there? And is there a pigeon gap? And while we pigeon ready? Well, so, you know, I'm fortunate in my position. I've been able to raise this with what you might euphemistically call senior security officials.
我对信鸽鸿沟的担忧始于我读到的一篇文章：中国人民解放军在近年来一直在训练1万只信鸽。原因在于他们担心，万一发生某种切断通信的网络攻击，他们就可以转而依靠信鸽。这让我感到担忧，并开始琢磨，我们作为一个国家是否对信鸽做好了准备？还是存在差距？我们为信鸽做好准备了吗？好吧，你知道的，我很幸运处在我的位置上。我能够将这个问题提出来，用你们委婉的话说，就是提交给高级安全官员。
And all I've got when I've raised the pigeon gap, they're kind of blank stares. You know, blank stares. You astound me, Gordon. Blank stares. When you bring up the issue of pigeons with tea or whatever. Blank stares. And so, you know, it worries me. I feel a bit like a kind of Churchillian voice in the wilderness.
而当我提出信鸽鸿沟时，我得到的只有茫然的凝视。你知道的，茫然的凝视。戈登，你让我大吃一惊。茫然的凝视。当你顺便提起关于鸽子的事情时。茫然的凝视。所以，你知道的，这让我很担心。我感觉自己有点像荒野中呼吁的丘吉尔式的声音。
You are, clearly. Warning about German disarmament. And so I do have this kind of hope by appearing on your podcast that people may listen. We need a network of military aviaries all across the country. If anyone from MI5 is listening to this, you know what you've got to do. Yeah, because it goes back to my point, you know, pigeons, you know, superheroes of history, you know, saved us from the kind of flood
显然是的。警告德国解除武装。所以我参加你们的播客确实抱有一种希望，希望大家能听进去。我们在全国各地需要一个军用信鸽网。如果军情五处有人在听这个节目，你们知道该怎么做。是的，因为这回到了我的观点，你知道，鸽子，你知道，历史上的超级英雄，你知道，把我们从某种洪水中拯救出来
through the Second World War, but they may, you know, in the event of some awful cyber attack and, you know, a kind of solar storm taking out all our communications, you know, we may rely on those pigeons flying free in our skies, you know, once more. And then people remember that, you know, perhaps it was this podcast that you know kind of turned the tide well if in
度过了第二次世界大战，但在某种可怕的网络攻击和某种太阳风暴导致我们所有通信瘫痪的情况下，你知道，我们可能会再次依靠那些在天空中自由飞翔的鸽子。然后人们会记住，你知道，也许正是这个播客扭转了乾坤。好吧，如果
any way we can play a humble role in saving britain that'd be great um i mean gordon on the topic of china i did see just when i was um doing some cursory research, that in November 2020, a racing pigeon sold for almost $2 million in China. So they're obviously very, very pigeon friendly in China. Absolutely. And so pigeon racing and pigeon breeding is still there and actually stronger perhaps in Asia, still quite strong in the Middle East, stronger in Asia. It's slightly... Well, they have it in Delhi, don't they willie dalrymple wrote uh wonderful stuff about the the pigeon races in in yeah and if you go around the middle east you can still see quite a bit of it in in countries there but yeah i mean you know the the the breeding of those pigeons to to to kind of a bit like racehorses to kind of
我们能以任何微薄的方式在拯救英国方面发挥作用，那就太棒了。嗯，戈登，关于中国这个话题，我在做一些粗略的研究时确实看到，在2020年11月，一只信鸽在中国拍出了近200万美元的高价。所以他们在对鸽子非常非常友好。当然。所以赛鸽和养鸽在亚洲依然存在，而且可能更强盛，在中东依然相当强盛，在亚洲则更强盛。这有点……好吧，他们在德里也有，威廉·达尔林普尔写过关于那里的赛鸽的精彩文章，是的，如果你去中东转转，你仍然可以在那里的国家看到不少这样的活动，但是，你知道，培育那些鸽子有点像赛马，为了
breed the best pigeons and this this you know this goes back to where we started this kind of domesticated nature the selective breeding is partly what makes pigeons interesting. It's why actually Darwin spends quite a bit of time in Origin and Species talking about pigeons, because of their ability to selectively breed them. And he kind of draws this analogy between artificial selection and natural selection. And so still the kind of breeding the fastest pigeon or the best pigeon or breeding the most beautiful pigeon. So there's always been this thing about pigeon fancying, where you breed these kind of beautiful looking birds. And that was something in Roman times.
培育出最好的鸽子，这可以追溯到我们的起点，这种驯化的天性，选择性育种正是鸽子如此有趣的部分原因。这也是为什么达尔文在《物种起源》中花了不少时间谈论鸽子，因为它们能够进行人工选择性育种。他在人工选择和自然选择之间做了这种类比。因此，培育最快的鸽子、最好的鸽子或者最美丽的鸽子一直存在。所以一直以来都有这种赛鸽爱好，即培育这些外表美丽的鸟类。这在古罗马时期就有了。
And also, still today, you will see these kind of ornate looking pigeons, which are being bred for their looks, and which again, are hugely valued. So Gordon, we've looked at the kind of the cultural uses of the pigeon, the way that it's kind of in full mythology and so on. And we've looked at the uses that humans over the span of history have put pigeons to. One final theme, which conveys kind of deeper truths about the relationship of humans to the animal kingdom, is that possibly the most shocking and notorious mass extinction featured a pigeon, specifically the passenger pigeon.
而且直到今天，你仍然会看到这些外表华丽的鸽子，它们是为了美观而培育的，同样也极具价值。所以，戈登，我们探讨了鸽子的文化用途，它如何融入神话等等。我们还探讨了人类在漫长历史中对鸽子的利用。最后一个主题传达了人类与动物王国关系的更深层次的真理，那就是最令人震惊和声名狼藉的大灭绝之一涉及一种鸽子，具体来说就是旅鸽。
So that's a terrible story. So just tell us a bit about that. Well, I mean, the passenger pigeons were, I mean, they were slightly different from our Columbia, Libya, our homing pigeon, but they lived in huge colonies. In the billions. In the billions. And I mean, people would say, I mean, particularly in North America,
这是一个可怕的故事。给我们讲讲吧。嗯，我是说，旅鸽跟我们的原鸽、家鸽有点不同，但它们生活在巨大的群落中。数以亿计。数以亿计。我是说，人们会说，特别是在北美，
and they moved in these huge flocks, and people would say it would sound like Niagara Falls, you know, when they moved, you know, and you'd almost feel the earth shake, because they were so enormous. Could I just read from John james audubon who you know the great ornithologist american ornithologist writing in 1813 and he describes um standing underneath the passenger pigeons going past the air was literally filled with pigeons the light of noonday was obscured as by an eclipse the dung fell in spots not unlike melting flakes of snow and the continued buzz of wings had a tendency to lull my senses to repose and he talks about um the pigeons were still passing in undiminished numbers and continued to do so for three days in succession i mean it's kind of absolutely stunning spectacle the sun
它们成群结队地移动，人们说当它们移动时听起来就像尼亚加拉大瀑布，你知道的，你甚至能感觉到大地在震动，因为它们太庞大了。我能引述一下约翰·詹姆斯·奥杜邦的话吗？你知道这位伟大的鸟类学家、美国鸟类学家在1813年写下的文字，他描述了自己站在飞过的旅鸽群下方的情景：天空完全被鸽子填满了，正午的光线像日食一样昏暗，粪便落下的斑点就像融化的雪花，翅膀持续的嗡嗡声有一种让我昏昏欲睡的倾向。他还谈到鸽子依然以不减的数量飞过，并且连续三天都是如此。我的意思是，这绝对是一个令人惊叹的壮观景象，太阳
blocked out for three days at a time by these passing flocks of pigeons yeah and their breeding garlands kind of covered hundreds of square miles but but basically they got they get shot for sport particularly and this is the same time as the buffalo being wiped out so it's kind of 1870 to 1890 by they're gone by i think the first world war certainly um but around the turn of the century you know billions are just killed like that and they're gone like the dodo yeah i was about to say the dodo so the dodo is a distant relative of the pigeon isn't it is that right yes a distant cousin i think a distant yeah distant cousin i mean and um i mean obviously pigeons themselves as in the what we recognize to be pigeons i mean
连续三天被这些飞过的鸽群遮蔽。是的，它们的繁殖地覆盖了数百平方公里。但基本上它们为了运动而被射杀，这与野牛被消灭的时间相同，所以大约在1870年到1890年之间，它们在我认为第一次世界大战之前就消失了，当然……但在世纪之交，数十万亿只就这样被杀死，它们像渡渡鸟一样消失了。是的，我正要说渡渡鸟。所以渡渡鸟是鸽子的远亲，对吗？是这样的吗？是的，我想是一个远亲，一个远亲。我的意思是，嗯……当然鸽子本身，也就是我们所认为的鸽子，我是说，
the issue that a lot of people have with pigeons is not that there are too few but there are too many so ken livingston was a notorious pigeon ofa-foe. Rats with wings. Rats with wings. So just on the rats with wings issue, is that a gross calumny, Gordon, on pigeons? Because there is, I mean, a lot of listeners to this will say, you know, I've seen them scavenging in Trafalgar Square. Pigeons are very bad fellows.
很多人对鸽子有意见，不是因为它们太少，而是因为它们太多了。所以肯·利文斯顿是一个著名的反鸽人士。带翅膀的老鼠。带翅膀的老鼠。那么关于带翅膀老鼠的问题，戈登，这对鸽子来说是不是一种严重的污蔑？因为有很多人听了这话会说，你知道的，我看到它们在特拉法加广场觅食。鸽子真是坏东西。
Do you think pigeons have been maligned? Oh, I absolutely think they're maligned and you know they are they you know they have this reputation somehow being you know it's interesting isn't it because in in ancient times you were hearing they were seen as kind of chaste and beautiful and now gods symbols of the gods and now we see them as the kind of dirty things you know in in trafalgar square and we've you know, people have been trying to get rid of them. And I think it's a tragedy because, you know, these are our friends who are there because, you know,
你觉得鸽子被诬蔑了吗？哦，我绝对认为它们被诬蔑了，你知道的，它们有这种名声，不知怎么的……这很有趣，不是吗？因为在古代，正如你所听到的，它们被视为纯洁美丽的东西，现在是神的化身、神的象征，而现在我们在特拉法加广场把它们视为肮脏的东西，你知道的，人们一直在试图摆脱它们。我认为这是一个悲剧，因为，你知道的，这些是我们的朋友，它们之所以在那里，是因为，你知道，
they've come with us into the cities. As we built these cities, you know, these pigeons, which most of the feral pigeons you see in the cities are actually the descendants of the ones we raised in the dovecots and the domesticated pigeons, and who've come with us in the cities and who have, as I said, saved us on many occasions. And yet we look down on them now. And so I do feel for pigeons and I feel they get a bad rap.
它们和我们一起进入了城市。随着我们建造这些城市，你知道，这些鸽子——你在城市里看到的绝大多数野鸽子，实际上都是我们在鸽舍里养大、被驯化的鸽子的后代——它们和我们一起进入城市，正如我所说，在许多场合拯救了我们。然而我们现在却看不起它们。所以我确实为鸽子感到难过，我觉得它们受了不白之冤。
That's been incredibly moving throughout the entire... Gordon, can I ask you one last question? Do you have a favourite cinematic pigeon? Oh, there's a few good ones, aren't there? I mean, what was that? There was that great cartoon. Is it Valiant? Is that the one I'm thinking of?
整个过程都令人无比感动……戈登，我能问你最后一个问题吗？你有没有最喜欢的电影鸽子？哦，有几个不错的，不是吗？我是说，那是什么？有一部很棒的动画片。是《勇敢的心》吗？是我在想的那部吗？
I can't remember now. But I don't have a particular favourite. Do you, Dominic? I do, yeah. I ask because I do, so I can finally contribute something meaningful to this pigeon-based discussion. So in Moonraker, when James Bond's gondola comes out
我现在记不清了。但我没有特别喜欢的。你呢，多米尼克？我有，是的。我问是因为我有，这样我终于可以为这个关于鸽子的讨论做出一些有意义的贡献了。所以在《太空城》中，詹姆斯·邦德的贡多拉船出来
into St. Mark's Square and transforms into a kind of car and people are sort of machine gunning him from behind and he goes across St. Mark's Square in this gondola, a pigeon does a double take um it's very it's a very yes I remember that yeah very it's a very humorous moment for those people who may be listening with some and there was also uh catch the pigeon wasn't there where Dick Dastardly and Muttley Dastardly yes yes the pigeon in uh in their flying machines yeah well Gordon it's been it's been an absolute treat absolutely worth
到圣马可广场，变成了一种汽车，人们从后面用机枪向他扫射，他坐着这只贡多拉穿过圣马可广场，一只鸽子双重确认般地看了一眼——这非常……这是一个非常……是的，我记得——非常幽默的时刻，对于那些可能带着某种心情聆听的人来说。还有“抓鸽子”对吧，迪克·达斯特利和穆特利？达斯特利，是的，是的，他们飞行器里的鸽子，是的。好吧，戈登，这真是一次绝对的享受，绝对值得
the the way an education hasn't it tom it's been a genuine education it really has well for me anyway and maybe not for you you're already it you were already converted in a file yeah i hope i made my case so thank you you did you made your case and you're brilliant and uh you may have saved britain as well well that's if you can close that pigeon gap, you will have performed a miraculous service. So the book is Operation Columba. That's right, isn't it? Yeah, the Secret Pigeon Service is the other title. The Secret Pigeon Service.
这一趟，也是一次教育，不是吗，汤姆？这真是一堂真正的教育课。确实如此。好吧，至少对我是这样，也许对你不是，你本来就已经皈依了。是的，我希望我表达了我的观点，谢谢你。你确实表达了观点，你太棒了，而且你可能也拯救了英国。好吧，如果你能弥合那个鸽子差距，你就完成了一项奇迹般的功绩。所以这本书是《鸽子行动》。没错，是吧？对，另一个书名是《秘密信鸽局》。《秘密信鸽局》。
And tons of stories of pigeon-based derring-do. Leaves the reader in absolute no doubt that it was the pigeon that won the Second World War and saved Europe from Nazism. So hurrah for the pigeons. And hurrah for you, Gordon, for coming on the show and braving the scepticism of some people. I don't know who they were.
里面有无数关于鸽子大显身手的英勇故事。毫无疑问地让读者确信，正是鸽子赢得了第二次世界大战并将欧洲从纳粹主义手中拯救出来。所以为鸽子欢呼吧。也为你欢呼，戈登，感谢你来到节目中并勇敢面对某些人的怀疑。我不知道他们是谁。
I don't know who they were. Thank you. So next week, the rest is history. We'll have an episode on crows and an episode on the starling. So much to come. Bye-bye. All right. Bye-bye.
我不知道他们是谁。谢谢。所以下周，历史余音。我们将有一集关于乌鸦的节目，还有一集关于椋鸟的节目。精彩内容即将呈现。再见。好的。再见。
Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前购买现场门票的权限，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。